- Should I just walk in
or should I do the whole
stopping every like five seconds?
So right now, my boyfriend
is in the other room,
and he thinks that we're here
just to talk about our dream wedding.
But, we're gonna surprise him
and put on a wedding dress.
- I hope he has a really good reaction
because it's something
that I've been waiting for
like 12 years.
You know when you see
those videos it's like
if I'm walking down the
aisle and my boyfriend
doesn't cry or have that reaction
I'm gonna go back and walk again.
- Tam and I think about
getting married all the time.
She may not know this,
but I think about it more
than she does simply
because she is so deserving.
- I am 30, she is 29, so we see ourselves
having kids in the next,
maybe, two and half years,
three years.
- My thing of a dream wedding is
just simply inviting all
our friends, all our family.
I want there to be a routine
that me and a couple of friends
and family practice
out on the dance floor,
and we do a special dance for 'em.
That's the only thing that I want.
- I would like to get married in a place
that resembles of a barn or a farm.
Not extremely fancy, but it's
still really well decorated.
- Okay I think this is the one.
I hope it fits.
I know women go back and forth and
trying dresses like a thousand times.
- Oh, that actually looks really nice.
- [Woman] Okay.
- You just have to stop eating
for, like, a good four days.
Just to fit into a dress like
this for your wedding day.
- I'm just so scared because
I've never been in a wedding dress before.
We've been to so many
weddings and stuff like that,
and it's always me
watching the other woman
getting married and
having the white dress on.
- This is really random and
probably very weird of me,
but I brought my grandma's pearls
'cause I figured if I'm
gonna try on a wedding dress
for the first time, I might
as well wear the accessories
I plan on wearing on the actual day.
- What makes me attracted to Callie
is, besides her looks, which
is not the most important
thing, is her character.
Her laughter is very contagious.
She is very understanding,
extremely intelligent.
She is a great whole person.
She is smart, as I said, and
knows how to dance very well,
and I'm blessed to be
able to be her partner.
- What I love about Tam is that
Tam is the complete opposite
of me.
Knowing myself in the past,
I am known to be very, very
complacent, just satisfied with who I was
and what I was doing in life.
I wanted to swim with the stream.
Thing about Tam is that she
swims against the stream.
She wants to dream a little.
She wants to go out and live.
- Oh no.
- When it comes to language
because you can always
talk to people based on ...
What's going on?
- [Callie] I don't know.
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
You look gorgeous.
- Awww.
(laughing)
How do you feel?
- Happy.
- Genuinely I'm nervous.
(laughing)
- Did you expect this?
- No, did you?
- Maybe.
- Since we're here, I was
wondering if you wanted
to just get married today.
(laughing)
I told them that
you were waiting for 12 years.
- Yeah it don't matter.
- I've been nervous all day long
because I really didn't
know what to expect.
- Are you sure?
- Let's just do it babe.
We came this far.
We might as well, you know?
It's been 12 years.
- Are you guys ready?
- I'm ready.
- Dearly beloved and honored guests,
just the three of you behind the cameras.
- You were asking me about
what would be my outfit
like for the wedding day.
And I was saying that
it'd be something classic
but is still stylish, I would
be wearing suspenders ...
- I now pronounce you man and wife.
You may kiss the bride.
(laughing)
- I love you.
- I love you, too.
(clapping)
- When I first seen her,
I was like, oh she looks so beautiful.
Oh, is she gonna sit down next to me?
I think we're gonna stand up,
and then I seen Steven
after and I was like,
wait, oh so that's what
kind of party we gonna have.
- The reaction that I thought
I was gonna get from him
was what's going on.
- I was like I'm not ready because
I don't have the real things here.
I'm not looking right.
- Like, I couldn't have
asked for a better reaction.
I mean, I didn't think that
you would cry honestly.
He's not really easily to cry.
- This is a person that I
really feel intrigued about,
attracted to, in love with, and yeah.
It's my sweaty girl right here.
(laughing)
- I feel liberated, like a
big weight has been lifted
off my shoulders because
it's been a long time coming.
Even if it was a prank,
I still feel the love,
and I still feel like it was ...
I really appreciate her
pranking the hell out of me.
- With her by my side, it doesn't matter.
Fears can come.
We're gonna go through anything.
- He's just the sweetest
person I've ever met,
so bring in the priest.
(laughing)
(gentle music)